قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه ومنذ انطلاق الصواريخ من غزه
الاسبوع الماضي اصدر تعليمته رفقه وزير
الدفاع بتصفيات تقطع ما سماها تسلل او
تسلسل القيادي للجهات في غزه واضاف
نتنياهو في اجتماع امنيا لحكومته ان
العمليه التي جاءت بجهد مشترك للجيش وجهاز
الشباك قامت بتصفيه كبار قاده الجهاد
الاسلاميه الثلاثه في غزه واشار نتنياهو
الى ان ما سماه ذراع اسرائيل الطويله تصل
الى كل ارهابي في الزمان والمكان الذي
تختاره حسب وصفه محذرا بعدم العبث مع
اسرائيل وقال نتنياهو ان حكومته مستعده
لاي سيناريو بعد الضربات على الجهاد
الاسلامي في قطاع غزه
وقبيل بدء جلسه المجلس الوزاري المصغر
تراس رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
جلسه لتقييم الاوضاع الامنيه وشدد نتنياهو
في كلمه لها عاقبه الاجتماع انه يجب على
اسرائيل التصدي لما سماها المخططات التي
تزعزع الامن والاستقرار مشيرا الى ان
اسرائيل ستستهدف كل من يقوم بالمساس بها
وكان صحيفه معاريف قد نقلت عن نتنياهو
قوله ان اسرائيل تستعد ليشن حرب على جبهات
متعدده
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان الجيش حقق جميع اهداف العمليه التي جرت
فجر اليوم في قطاع غزه والتي سماها اجسام
الواقي وقال الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
في ان عمليه غزه نقلت رساله واضحه وقويه
مفادها ان من يطلق الصواريخ على
لن يكون ولن يبقى محصنا على حد تعبيره
بهذه العمليه نقلت اسرائيل رساله قويه
مفادها ان من يطلق الصواريخ وغلاف غزه في
وضح نهار او يوجه عمليات تخريبيه ضد
مواطنين اسرائيليين لن يكون ولن يبقى
محسنا